اتفاقيه منع جريمه الاباده الجماعيه
اعتمدت امميا في التاسع من ديسمبر عام
48 اشترطت مادتها الثانيه توفر الكليه او
الجزئيه لقصد اباده جماعه ما على اساس
قومي او عرقي او جنسي او ديني بالاقدام
على قتل اعضاء من الجماعه او الحاق اذى
جسدي او روحي خطير باعضاء من الجماعه او
اخضاع الجماعه عمدا لظروف معيشيه يراد بها
تدميرها المادي كليا او جزئيا او فرض
تدابير تستهدف الحقول دون انجاب الاطفال
داخل الجماعه او نقل اطفال من الجماعه
عنوه الى جماعه اخرى كما نصت الماده
الثالثه من الاتفاقيه على الافعال التي
يعاقب عليها وهي الاباده الجماعيه التامر
على ارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه التحريض
المباشر والعلني على ارتكاب الاباده
الجماعيه محاوله ارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه
الاشت راك في الاباده الجماعيه وبحسب
الماده الرابعه فانه لا يتمتع اي شخص
بحصانه ضد تهمه الاباده الجماعيه سواء
كانوا حكاما دستوريين او موظفين عامين او
افرادا ووفقا للماده الخامسه يتعهدوا
المتعاقدون بان يتخذوا كل طبقا لدستور
التدابير التشريعيه اللازمه لضمان انفاذ
احكام هذه الاتفاقيه اما الماده السادسه
فنصت على محاكمه الاشخاص المتهمين امام
محكمه مختصه من محاكم الدوله التي ارتكب
الفعل على ارضها او امام محكمه جزائيه
دوليه